в
[Музика]
про захоплююче щось подібне також можна знайти в
Берлін не просто так не хоче
у всякому разі вже не так багато художників
площа доступна і
що але й уся справа тільки на
створюється хвилинний час, який робить це
Звичайно, навіть більш захоплююче, ніж це
у всякому разі вже тому, що все, що ви
тут бачить усіх робітників
є квазітимчасовим
тому на початку ми, звичайно, маємо один одного
також подумав, що дуже шкода, якщо
все, що ми створюємо тут і
дизайн, куди ми вкладаємо душу та серце
покласти, що буде знищено
але саме це робить його таким, яким він є
ефемерний і ефемерний берлін має
жоден план Берліна не полегшує це, а я
Думаю, це найкращий доказ
культура та інше
а також капіталізм в одному місці
схопили разом і лише одну
чудовий результат зачарував